welcome back when i left off i was
hurrying a little bit but we had
hopefully come to the conclusion that if
i have a simple lever like i have here
and i know the distance is from where
i'm applying the force
to the fulcrum to the pivot and i know
the distance from the pivot to where the
machine is essentially applying the
force or the machine being the lever in
the situation i know the relationship
between the two forces i'm applying the
input force so actually i shouldn't call
this force too i should call this input
force well anyway the input force times
the distance from the input force to the
fulcrum
is equal to the output force
times the distance from the output force
to the fulcrum and that all fell out of
what we did in the last video of the
conservation of energy and that the work
in
has to equal the work out and all work
is is a transfer of energy so the
transfer of energy in has to be the
transfer of energy out assuming we have
no friction and none of the energy is
lost and how is this useful
well i could say
we could do a bunch of problems with
this
let's say that
let's say that i have a
a 100 newton object right here
100 newtons
and let's say that i know
no matter what i do my my maximum
strength that i could push well let me
let me draw this a little different
let's say it's like this because my goal
is to lift the 100 newton object so the
100 newton object is right here that's
100 newtons and let's let's say i know
that the maximum downward force that i
am capable of applying is only 10
newtons right so i want my force to be
multiplied by 10 to lift this force so
let's figure out what would happen my
input force is
and i want to figure out the distance of
to the full so let's say my input force
is 10 and let's call this the input
distance
and i want the output force to be 100
right
and let's call this the output distance
right so if i have a fulcrum here
this is the input distance
and this is the output distance let me
switch colors it's getting monotonous
this is the output distance from here to
here and let's figure out what the ratio
has to be for the input output
for the ratio of the input distance to
the output distance well if we just
divide both sides by 10 we get the
distance input
it has to be 10 times the distance
output right 100 divided by 10.
so if the distance from the fulcrum to
the weight is i don't know 5 meters
then the distance from where i'm
applying the force
to the fulcrum has to be 10 times that
it has to be 50 meters
so no matter what the ratio of this
length to this length has to be 10. and
now what would happen
if i designed this machine in this way i
will be able to apply 10 newtons here
which is my maximum strength 10 newtons
downwards
and i will lift 100 newton object and
now what's the trade-off though you know
nothing just pops out of thin air the
trade-off is is that i am going to have
to push
down for a much longer distance for
actually 10 times the distance as this
object is going to move up
and once again i know that because the
work in has to equal the work out i
can't i'll um through some magic magical
machine and if you were to able to
invent one you you shouldn't watch this
video and you should go build it and
become a trillionaire but
a machine can never generate work out of
thin air or can never generate energy
out of thin air that energy has to come
from some place most machines actually
you lose energy to friction or whatever
else
but in this situation if i'm putting in
10 newtons of force times some distance
whatever that quantity is of work
the work cannot change the total work it
can go down if this there's some
friction in the system
so let's do another problem
and really they're all kind of of the
same formula and then i'll move into a
few other types of
of of simple systems
and once again just to
i should use the line tool
make this up on the fly
you could always create problems where
you can compound it further and et
cetera et cetera using some of the other
concepts we learned but don't worry
about that right now
so let's say that
i have
i have a
i'm going to push up here well now let
me see what i want to do
i want to
push down here
with a force of
let's say that this distance right here
let's say this distance is 35 meters
this distance
is 5 meters and let's say i'm going to
push down with a force of 7 newtons and
what i want to figure out is how heavy
of an object can i lift here
how heavy of an object
well all we have to do is use the same
formula that the moments and i know i
used that word once before so you might
not know what it is but the moments on
both sides of the fulcrum have to be the
same or the input moment has to be the
output moment so what's the moment again
well the moment is just the force times
the distance from the force to the
fulcrum so the input moment is 7 newtons
times 35
meters and realize that that is not work
because the distance this force is
traveling is not 35 meters the distance
this force traveling is something like
here
but this 35 meters is going to be
proportional to the distance that this
is traveling when you compare it to this
other side
so this quantity 7 newton times 35
meters is the moment and that is going
to be equal to
the moment on this side the output
moment so that is equal to
5 meters times the force that i'm
lifting or the lifting force of the
machine
times let's say the force out
so we can figure out the force out by
just dividing both sides by five
so let's see 35 divided by 5 is 7 so you
get 7 times 7
equals a force out
or 49 newtons
and you could see that because you can
see that the length of this side of the
lever is seven times the length of this
side of the lever
so when you input a force of seven you
output a force of seven times that and
of course in order to move the block one
meter up
in this direction you're gonna have to
push down for seven meters and that's
where we know that the work on the input
work is equal to the output work well
anyway hopefully i didn't confuse you
but
and you have a reasonable sense of how
levers work in the next couple of videos
i'll introduce you to other
machines simple machines like a wedge
i've always had trouble calling a wedge
a machine but it is one and pulleys i'll
see in the next videos